NIKOLAJ EHLERS HAS IT.
EHLERS WILL LEAD FOR STNIGHT, I
THEIR START TO THE GAME. BEHIND
JONES FOR THE GAME'S OPENING
OR THE CHICAGO
BLACKHAWKS.
AND WHAT A CHANCE FOR PIERRE- I
BOARDS.
CONNOR BACK FOR PIONK.
PIONK WALKS IT TO THE TOP OF TH
HOCKEY SENSE.
EVERYBODY IS OUT OF POSITION.
EHLERS WOULD BAY GOALS, THAT LET
RECALLED FOR THE HAWKS
NATE SCHMIDT, SCHMIDTFRONT, JON
LEADERS ON TIME ON ICE EVERY
GAME.
KANE.S
DeBRINCAT IS ON IT, KANE WORKS
IT OUT  DeBRINCAT
WAS THERE -- CARPENTER, RATHER,E
STRUCTURE.
ONE TIME BOBBLED IN
DETERMINE IF IT WAS OFF-SIDE
TWO HAWKS.AL.
[ Cheers and Applause ]
>> Dennis: THAT- INTERCEPTED,
SPIN-O-RAMA AND DID MARC-AN THE
DUBOIS NOT ABLE TO GET A
HAD THE OPENING GOAL AND
TONINATO MADE IT LOOK EASY.
NATURAL BORN KYLE CONNOR, GIVES
THENSITION HERE.
WHAT A WEAPON IT'S BROUGHT
OUT BY DACH.
FORMER SASKATOON BLADE WILL PUT
NET, SCHEIFELE AND MARC-ANDRÉ
FLEURY CAME ACROSST ASIDE, SCORK
FOR COMRIE, AND HE RESPECTSWHEE,
BACK FOR SCHEIFELE., THAT BROUG.
SAVE MADE, REBOUND,DRÉ
FLEURY WITH A BIG GLOVE SAVE.
HE'LL DROP ITLINE.
NATE SCHMIDT PUTS IT BACK.
GREAT PAD SAVE BY FLEURY,SIGHT.
THAT'S WHAT THIS LINE DOES
BETTER THAN ANYTHING IS GETTING
THE
LAST TIME THEY MET THE FIRST
IN THE NATIONAL HOCKEY LEAGUE
WITH EHLERS THROWS ONE BEHIND
ONE OF THEAY.
PIERRE-LUC DUBOIS SPINS AND
FIRES.
SAVE MADE.